Philippe de Montréal nous a demandé s'il
est vrai que le bicarbonate de soude est
efficace pour éliminer les pesticides
sur les fruits et légumes en 2019 des
chercheurs de l'Université du
Massachusetts ont trempé des pommes
traitée avec deux pesticides
habituellement à utiliser en agriculture
dans une solution de bicarbonate de
soude pendant 15 minutes résultat après
avoir rincé les pommes il ne restait
plus de traces de pesticides à la
surface des fruits la plupart des
pesticides ne sont pas stables à un pH
alcalin comme c'est le cas dans une
solution d'eau et de bicarbonate de
soude il se décompose donc naturellement
et sont éliminés par contre ce nettoyage
ne permet pas d'éliminer les pesticides
dans la chair du fruit